Salut !
Mathématicien, peintre,
écrivain, acteur de cinéma.
Des disciplines dans lesquelles on trouve
toujours des génies dans l'humanité.
Mais entre Vincent Van Gogh qui se découpe
son oreille pour la donner à
une prostituée,
ça c'est cadeau.. Gérard de Nerval
qui promenait son homard en laisse,
ou encore, Andy Warhol qui collectionnait
les croûtes de pizza.
Est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas un grain
de folie dans les grains de génie?
Voici les six histoires vraies
qui montrent que, parfois, les génies
ne sont pas tous seuls dans leur tête.
Bertrand, René,
Jean-Jacques, Marcel, Loïc...
parce que, il n'est pas tout seul non
plus dans sa tête...
... générique
John Nash Junior est né en 1928
en Virginie occidentale et cet homme,
c'est un brillant mathématicien
et économiste qui va partir en vrille.
Mais alors vraiment bien comme il faut.
Tout se passe pour le mieux.
On est en 1950.
Il est l'auteur d'une série d'articles
portant sur les équilibres
non-coopératifs.
Plus tard rebaptisés les équilibres
de Nash... ça vous fait une belle jambe.
Il enseigne à l'Institut
de technologie du Massachusetts.
Il y rencontre l'amour de sa vie, Alicia,
et en pleine guerre froide,
il est embauché par le département
de la Défense pour décrypter d'éventuels
messages codés que les Russes
planqueraient habilement dans
la presse quotidienne.
Mais... Il y a toujours un mais..
il commence à croire voir
des messages codés extraterrestres
dans les lignes du New York Times.
Voilà, voilà.
Du coup, à la fin des années 50,
son état commence à inquiéter un peu son
entourage
parce qu'il refuse un poste de professeur
à l'Université de Chicago
en précisant qu'il s'attend bientôt à être nommé
Empereur de l'Antarctique
par les extraterrestres !
Ehh... avec les pingouins...
Nash commence en fait
à sombrer dans une schizophrénie
paranoïaque dont il ne sortira que 30 ans plus tard,
au début des années 90,
période à laquelle il réalise enfin sa
conférence pour le prix Nobel d'économie,
qu'il recevra en 1994 pour ses travaux
qu'il avait fait quand même
quarante ans plus tôt.
Et il est mort en 2015, à l'âge de 86 ans,
dans un accident malheureux
de la route avec sa femme Alicia.
Si vous souhaitez en savoir plus sur cet homme,
Russell Crowe,
l'interprète dans un film sorti en 2001 :
"Un homme d'exception".
À la fin de cette vidéo,
je vous expliquerai comment devenir, vous
aussi, un génie... Et sans accès de folie, heureusement.
En téléchargeant des données
dans votre tête grâce au partenaire
de cette vidéo : Koober
L'application qui propose des versions
condensées de milliers de livres
et des meilleurs livres et des contenus
à lire ou à écouter en moins de 20 minutes.
Les 200 premiers auront
accès à un mois d'essai gratuit.
Le lien dans la description et on
s'en reparle tout à l'heure.
Grigori Perelman est un chercheur russe,
né en 1966,
qui vit avec sa mère
dans la banlieue de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Une vie classique,
à la différence près que cet homme est
un génie qui a refusé un prix
d'un million de dollars.
Petit retour en arrière.
En 1904, Henri Poincaré formule
une conjoncture
mathématique qui reste encore un mystère
presque un siècle plus tard,
puisque personne n'a réussi à faire
la démonstration.
On pourrait d'ailleurs
faire une vidéo sur ce genre de mystère.
Si ça vous dit, vous écrivez :
mystère mi quelque chose dans les commentaires.
Genre mystère... mimolette
ou mi-raisin.
En l'an de grâce 2000,
un million de dollars est mis en jeu
par l'Institut Clay pour récompenser
celui ou celle qui va trouver la solution
à la conjecture de Poincaré.
En 2002, justement,
Grigori Perelman publie gratuitement
sur Internet ses recherches sur le sujet.
Après quatre ans de vérification,
le verdict tombe : la conjecture de Poincaré
a bel et bien été résolue par Perelman.
Certains considèrent même que son travail
servira un jour à nous éclairer
sur la forme de l'univers.
Rien que ça !
On ne parle pas d'un mec qui a trouvé
juste comment tricher à Fall Guys
en retenant l'autre au moment de sauter...
.. et que c'est bien relou, par exemple.
Perelman devient donc une
véritable référence dans son milieu.
Mais l'homme n'est pas
préparé à cette consécration.
Il quitte son poste de chercheur,
annonce son retrait du monde des maths
et démarre une vie de reclus
dans son appartement avec maman.
Et en 2006, il refuse la médaille.
En 2010, l'Institut Clay veut lui remettre
le prix du millénaire ainsi
que le million d'euros promis.
Mais Perelman refuse.
Il déclare alors : je sais
comment gouverner l'univers,
pourquoi devrais je
courir après un million?
En vrai, ça se tient.
Le mec, il n'a pas tort, tort.
Faut dire que là, Empereur
de l'Antarctique.. euh...
"Il gouverne l'univers" .. lui, il gouverne l'univers, ok?
Avant de s'intéresser à celui qui collectionnait
les croûtes de pizza et
à celui qui promenait son homard
dans les jardins du Palais-royal,
parlons de celui qui offrait ses
oreilles en guise d'amour ...
... je t'aime.
À son époque, Van Gogh était
incompris et ignoré.
D'ailleurs, il aurait vendu
qu'une seule toile de son vivant.
Sa santé n'était pas au top.
Il souffrait d'hallucinations
visuelles et auditives.
La veille du réveillon de Noël de l'année 1888,
il reçoit un courrier de son frère
Théodorus,
qui était son seul soutien financier, et affectif d'ailleurs,
qui lui
annonce qu'il va se marier.
Et Vincent panique et s'imagine déjà exclu
de la nouvelle vie
de famille de son frère.
Le même jour, son ami Paul Gauguin,
avec qui il avait commencé à travailler,
ne le supporte plus et se
barre pour rentrer sur Paris.
Suite à ça, Vincent se tranche
une oreille au coupe choux.
C'est les gros rasoirs comme ça.
Et il dit
je vais la donner à une prostituée
pour lui prouver mon amour.
Et même là, il se plante parce que ce
n'était pas une prostituée.
En vrai, c'était la femme de ménage
d'un bordel de l'époque.
Alors, il y a d'autres versions qui existent,
comme celle qui mettrait en cause Gauguin,
qui lui aurait lui même tranché
l'oreille.. à Van Gogh.
Mais ça, on n'est pas sûr, sûr...
On est sûr qu'il n'avait plus d'oreille, par contre.
Il y a des dizaines et des dizaines
de diagnostics qui ont été émis concernant
l'état de santé de Van Gogh.
Et tous sont divergents.
L'abus d'alcool,
le manque de sommeil qui serait peut-être
à l'origine de son épilepsie,
elle même à l'origine des troubles de son
comportement, plus l'anxiété,
les délires hallucinatoires.
Ces troubles l'auraient même poussé à manger
plusieurs fois sa propre peinture.
Un peu la toile.. Un peu pour moi !
Qui ne connaît pas les
célèbres portraits colorés d'Andy Warhol.
L'artiste, qui est décédé en 1987,
étend son influence artistique dès
le début des années 60,
peint les stars de l'époque.
Il dessine au moins 50
pochettes de disques.
Bref, c'est la Resta !
Il prend également en photo tout ce
qu'il peut, de jour comme de nuit.
C'est un délire qu'il a et c'est près
de 60.000 clichés qu'il
conservera scrupuleusement.
Et justement, en parlant de conserver,
Warhol entassait pas mal de choses chez lui,
beaucoup trop de choses, en fait.
En 74, la Factory,
l'atelier d'artistes qu'avait ouvert Warhol à New-York,
change de locaux
pour aller s'installer à Broadway.
Suite à ce déménagement, il décide de conserver
des centaines de cartons vides.
Il va les remplir de photos, de dessins,
de coupures de presse,
de billets de concerts,
de notes de restaurant, de tickets de
caisse, mais aussi de croûtes de pizza !
Quand il mange une pizza, il garde les croûtes,
et les met dans un carton.
Le message n'est pas clair,
mais... Pourquoi pas ? ...
Il crée ainsi une collection
de 612 cartons remplis de centaines
d'objets chacun qui servent
à rien et, à la mort de Warhol,
ces boîtes et leur contenu sont les stars
d'expositions nommées Time Capsules, à travers le monde.
Alors que c'était
un mouvement artistique,
une vraie collection ou juste
un syndrome de Diogène?
On ne sait pas tellement.
N'empêche que les 612 boîtes sont aujourd'hui
conservées par le
Warhol Museum de Pittsburgh.
Et je me dis... bah
dans le doute, gardez des trucs,
on ne sait jamais..
Y-en a qui font des collecs avec des croûtes !
Dans la première moitié du 19e siècle,
Gérard de Nerval (c'était
un écrivain et un poète français)
c'était l'un des talents les plus
prometteurs du mouvement romantique
et à la fin des années 1830,
alors qu'il n'a même pas encore 30 ans d'ailleurs,
ses premières crises apparaissent.
Mais, c'est à la suite d'une déception amoureuse
avec une comédienne
que le poète sombre définitivement.
J'adore cette histoire.
En 1841, dans les jardins du Palais-royal,
qui c'est qu'on voit passer en train
de promener son homard en laisse?
C'est Gérard..
Gérard, il promène son homard,
attaché à un petit ruban bleu,
sous les yeux des passants qui trouvent
cet animal de compagnie pas très commun.
Et lui se justifie en demandant
en quoi un homard,
c'est plus ridicule qu'un chien,
qu'un chat, qu'une gazelle, qu'un lion
ou qu'une autre bête?
... bah, quand même Gérard,
par exemple c'est un homard quoi...
Ensuite, il enchaîne les crises.
Nerval se prend pour un oiseau en pleine
rue, dans le plus simple appareil...
C'est à dire à poil !
Il lui arrive de se prendre
aussi pour le neveu de Napoléon.
Au final, il passera plusieurs mois
dans une clinique à Montmartre.
Mais tout le reste de sa vie,
Nerval aura du mal à distinguer
ses rêves de la vie réelle.
Il est victime de visions
et de délires hallucinatoires.
En 1855, à 46 ans,
Nerval sera malheureusement retrouvé
pendu près de la place du Châtelet.
Vivien Leigh est l'une des plus
grandes comédiennes de son époque.
Vous ne la connaissez pas, mais à l'époque,
on ne connaissait qu'elle!
Elle est née en 1913.
Elle est devenue actrice de renom
au théâtre dans les années 30.
En 1937, elle joue aux côtés de l'acteur
Lawrence Olivier,
qui ne tarde pas à découvrir que Leigh est
sujette à de gros changements radicaux
d'humeur, mais en mode
mauvaise humeur... sa maman.
Sa réputation d'actrice difficile
commence à se répandre dans le milieu.
Elle insulte régulièrement
ses partenaires de jeu.
Sur "Autant en emporte le vent", pour lequel elle
obtient quand même un Oscar en 1940,
elle trouve que Clark Gable,
son amant à l'écran, a mauvaise haleine.
Elle ne se gêne pas pour lui dire.
Elle lui murmure à l'oreille pour le
déstabiliser pendant les scènes d'amour.
Et un soir, le réalisateur lui reproche
d'être trop "Lady" dans son interprétation.
Et bien le lendemain, elle vient avec
le corsage déchiré avec les seins à l'air.
Et elle dit : "ça va là, ça fait assez salope?"
Voilà... Vraiment elle a un accès
à la critique assez difficile.
Elle est atteinte de tuberculose en 1944
et ses sautes d'humeur sont
de plus en plus fréquentes.
Le fait qu'elle fume jusqu'à quatre
paquets par jour, ça doit pas
arranger le truc non plus.
Et elle devient incontrôlable
sur les plateaux comme à la vie,
elle devient bipolaire,
elle insulte extrêmement violemment son mari,
jusqu'à parfois
en perdre connaissance !
Ouais, Loïc, je trouve vraiment .. t'es une vieille salamandre !
Insulter à en perdre connaissance.
T'imagines la rage qu'il faut avoir!
À la suite du tournage de "Un tramway nommé Désir",
pour lequel elle obtient
d'ailleurs un second Oscar?
Vivien commence à se comporter comme son
personnage en buvant,
en passant beaucoup de temps auprès
d'hommes beaucoup plus jeunes qu'elle,
et dans les années 60, sa maladie empire
et elle sombre dans la dépression.
Sur son dernier film,
elle terrifie l'équipe de tournage
et doit subir des électrochocs entre les prises !
Des électrochocs, entre les prises ....
Malheureusement,
sa tuberculose aura raison d'elle en 1967,
à l'âge assez jeune de 53 ans.
Selon un rapport sur la santé dans le monde,
une personne sur quatre
souffrirait de troubles mentaux.
Ça fait plus de 300 millions de personnes
dans le monde qui sont
touchées par la dépression.
1.600.000 personnes en France
sont atteintes de troubles bipolaires.
C'est entre 15 et 25 ans que les troubles psychiatriques
apparaissent
en grande majorité.
Donc, en vrai,
pensez à consulter si des symptômes apparaissent
ou à accompagner
les personnes qui en ont besoin.
Je vous en avais parlé au début de la vidéo
et aussi il y a quelques mois
et aussi il y a quelques années,
lorsque j'avais
découvert l'application Koober
C'est une application qui permet d'accéder
à des synthèses de plus de 1500
livres au format audio ou écrit.
Et avant de rentrer dans le détail,
sachez que vous avez déjà un mois gratuit
pour tester l'application via
le lien dans la description.
Vous allez vite vous rendre compte
que c'est un peu le futur
de la transmission de savoir.
Et pour celles et ceux qui veulent continuer,
après l'essai d'un mois,
vous avez 20 euros de réduction
sur l'abonnement annuel,
ce qui le fait descendre à 59 euros 99.
Comme je vous disais,
je peux en parler facilement parce
que je suis un utilisateur régulier pour deux raisons :
déjà parce que ça me permet de comprendre
l'essentiel d'un livre
avant de potentiellement l'acheter
en version complète.
Et puis ensuite,
pour voir si c'est vraiment ce que je cherche,
si le contenu me correspond.
Et surtout de comprendre et retenir
l'essentiel d'un sujet sans consacrer
des heures et des heures dessus.
Alors quand je parle de sujet, je parle
de développement personnel et de savoir.
Il n'y a pas de résumés de fiction,
ça n'aurait aucun intérêt.
Un exemple en ce moment,
il y a l'émergence des NFT
On ne va pas se mentir,
je ne m'y connais pas du tout
en ce qui concerne la blockchain,
j'ai donc lu le com du best
seller "Big Bang Blockchain".
Et moins de 25 minutes plus tard,
je connaissais les grands principes.
Les smart contracts,
c'est l'utilisation en économie,
mais aussi dans la vie démocratique.
Bref, j'avais téléchargé l'essentiel
de la donnée dans ma tête.
Plus besoin d'être un génie
pour comprendre ces sujets.
C'est cool, non ?
Toutes les thématiques sont traitées sur Koober :
psychologie, dev perso, arts,
divertissement, sciences, etc.
Et une nouveauté aussi est arrivée,
il s'agit de ce qu'ils appellent
les formations qu'ils ont composé de coms,
d'interviews,
de documentaires et de quizz.
Et c'est très efficace pour explorer à fond une thématique.
Mais un essai valant plus que de longues explications,
je vous recommande de tester l'App via le lien
qui vous donne accès à un mois gratuit
et à 20 euros de réductions
sur l'abonnement annuel.
Merci Koober !
Moi, je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
salut, c'est moi !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne
et activer la cloche pour ne
pas rater la prochaine vidéo.
Ici, je vous mets une vidéo sur 6 choses
que vous saviez peut être pas sur le QI,
et la, je vous mets une vidéo sur...
Sur quoi Loïc?
sur .. heu.. ouais..
6...
Mais on ne va pas dire la suite.
Prenez soin de vous, à très bientôt.
Tchao!